[Music]
we got one router left miss jolt and a
stern earpods Pro in that's me
regretting this idea I had to test how
well these things stay in your ears I
even had to double down on my testing
with one of New York City's most iconic
dance families
[Music]
why did I do this because unlike the
$159 regular earpods
the $249 air pods Pro have active noise
cancellation they come with three
different size silicon rubber tips to
better fit your ear plus air pods have
been known to fall out
[Music]
there's even a size test that analyzes
the fit when they're in your ears and
tells you if you're all good heck apples
so confident in the fit they made them
sweat resistant for working out
I tested four wireless earbuds on the
bowl the standard air pods the air pods
Pro the Samsung Galaxy buds and the
Amazon echo buds with each pair in I
asked the bull operator to drive at
three speeds slow medium and high the
regular air pods stayed in on all the
tests one
[Music]
galaxy bug in Amazon echo buds the
Amazon echo buds fared the worst
falling out both times I felt a Mazon
does include these wingtips in the box
which should help though even then
there's still the least comfortable of
the bunch I'm not sure this was my best
idea the air pod pros would not fall out
no matter how many times I was bucked
off they just stayed secure in my ears
didn't really loosen up more good news
about the pros
if you're ever riding a mechanical bull
while trying to enjoy some music as one
does the pros active noise-cancelling
blocked out the machinery better than
those other competitors of course that
could also mean it would block out the
sound of an oncoming train or car that's
why there's a transparency you switch it
on via the phone or by pressing on this
little button to hear more noises around
you okay so the air pods Pro survived
the mechanical bull but I had to find
one more test just to be sure
this is tic-tac oh and ty not only to
tick in tack do crazy tricks but they're
twins with similar ears so I gave them
two pairs of ear pods bro and well got
out of the way their pods are staying in
again the air pods Pro stayed in
insanely well are they in there's still
in even had tight esta
[Music]
Oh
and with that we finally got the air
pods Pro to fall out with the series of
flips for me yes after all of that it
turns out aggressive chewing is what can
loosen up the inner seal still these
things stay in extremely well did it
come out